renaissance man.
what does it mean to call someone that?
the Oxford English Dictionary dates the
first use of the term back to 1906
and offers the less than completely helpful definition.
one who exhibits the virtues of an idealized man
of the Renaissance.
and in fact, this idea,
if not the precise term,
does originate during what we now call
the Italian Renaissance
in the 15th century.
in brief, the kind of man who was called
in the 20th century a Renaissance or universal man,
and who might now be called a polymath,
is someone who acquires knowledge and skill
in a whole range of different subjects and disciplines.
um, Nicholas,
isn't that fancy way to say Jack of all traits?
don't get smart with me.
that's another TikTok.
but why Renaissance?
well, the word means rebirth.
and as Europe slowly recovered from the devastation
wrought by the Black Plague in the mid 13 hundreds,
greater wealth and changes in social,
political and religious power structures set the
stage for a renewed appreciation of the distant past.
possibly in preference to the horrors of recent history,
Northern Italy had retained the remnants of
Roman civilization.
and in the 14th century,
poet and enthusiastic scholar of classic Latin,
Francesco Petroica,
better known today as Petrarch,
developed a humanist philosophy
in which a person's secular accomplishments
could coexist with an authentic relationship with God.
as writing from the ancient Greek,
scholars such as Aristotle,
Homer, Plato
and Ptolemy arrived in Italy,
through the 14 hundreds,
those ideas were incorporated into a new world view
that elevated man to a primary place in the universe,
morally obligated to use whatever gifts he possessed
to their fullest extent.
men of the Renaissance sought to embody
the basic tenant of Renaissance humanism
that humans are
limitless in their capacity for development.
those who had the ability,
the means, and opportunity
stroll for intellectual,
physical, social,
and artistic excellence.
and while many people cite
Leonardo da Vinci as the primary example of this ideal,
an earlier and possibly even more brilliant
exemplar was architect,
painter, poet, scientist,
mathematician,
classic scholar,
horseman, and athlete
Leon Batista Alberti,
whose motto was that a man can do all things if he will.
yeah, he definitely gets the title of